um and i don't know i don't find these
questions just so you know
yeah well listen if you came on the show
where we play spot the [ __ ] will you
will you play that with us it would be
awesome if you came on and played spot
the [ __ ] with
with not gay jared sure i'll play spot
the trony as long as they don't get cold
men
what if they are men some of them that's
the thing some of them are and some of
them aren't that's the key to the game
well that's the key well unless well
well some of them are cisgender woman
and some of them are transgender
women but you don't know that's why you
have to guess so the whole point is that
in guessing you might be guilty of hate
speech theron that's the key to the game
all right we are back sorry we had a
little misconnection there but
i want to bring our next guest right in
has a youtube channel i don't know the
name
um but uh is a libertarian
uh transsexual transgender i don't know
the terminology but because this person
is a libertarian i don't think
i'm going to be condemned theron meyer
thank you for being on the program
thanks for having me steven it's lovely
to be on so now okay
now you're in canada though right yes i
am i'm in vancouver
it's 5 20 am here and i woke up at 3.
well thank you very much for being on
the show we appreciate it
um we're the english accent are you from
england
i'm from south africa oh south africa
that's a tough one too because
sometimes a south african accent like
when leonardo dicaprio does it it sounds
like a bad australian accent
oh my goodness was it bad and you know
what dicaprio does it
uh yeah he just shouldn't do it okay
all right so you are a do you consider
you know listen it's no secret where i
line up
uh i just find things funny um where do
you line up do you call yourself
transsexual transgender
um what's the term is is [ __ ] a hate
word if i'm working on my car
well i guess it's just about the intent
when you use training i use training all
the time
um i think it's a funny word i don't
take myself so seriously
uh i think people are way too uh
narcissistic and self-obsessed and they
should get over themselves honestly
well okay so you're you're uh uh
transgender whatever the the term is so
we'll just
say whatever it determines okay so
whatever term we use interchangeably
that way when no one will take offense
um now you were upset or someone else
was upset
saying well why don't you have someone
else who's actually transgender in the
show i said well i have had people on
the show
and you allege that that person wasn't
really educated and this is someone who
wrote a book
left hander in london and um she debated
a lesbian who disagreed with the
transgender movement so
i want to be fair what is it that you
think i've done on the program
that was i guess unfair i don't think
um you necessarily were being unfair
i think you can have whoever you want on
your show i was just like
i felt like there was lacking um trans
women
from the political right okay
i don't think that's necessarily unfair
though
of course of course i didn't know you
existed you're like a unicorn
um so i mean it wasn't like it wasn't
like i was trying to
like don't let laboratory and try nice
on the show it was just like i didn't
know any of them existed they
i get angry emails all the time and you
you said though we talked about that um
52 year old man who's now acting like a
six-year-old girl
you find that absurd i do i
i think that's just i i was listening to
an interview with this person
and he basically said um that he's
acting this way as a way of coping with
his
pain and aware he called it play
therapy or whatever right i find that
upsetting because
um me being trans is just who i am it's
not me trying to
uh go through some therapy you go
through some
try to deal with with some pain in my
life it's just what it is
this person is co-op and co-opting that
for their mental illness
uh for their psychological
uh problems and just on that topic you
know
we do have people who are trans ager and
our
and our in our society they're called
mentally [ __ ] you know
they there are people um who are
these are people but how is it fair for
you to lob that criticism to them
and say that's not fair for someone to
say well if you're a male
and you have male anatomy and you want
to be a female that that would be a
a mental condition as well why is one
the age thing
not reasonable and the sex if you if you
if you look at
if you look at um if you look at the
brain
of let's say that stephanie person you
would find the brain
a fully developed 43 year old male brain
uh you won't find a six-year-old brain
however there's a lot of research and
it's kind of growing it's quite a new
field but there's a lot of research
showing the inter
intersex anatomy brain anatomy
of uh trans men and trans women uh there
are certain parts including like the
brain stem and the hypothalamus
that very closely resemble uh the their
gender identity
so i've read some of that i'm not entire
we'll bring you on for another segment
too
i'm not entirely convinced of that and
especially when you look at you know
john hopkins
you know basically the place that that
created sexual reassignment surgery
saying no we
we we we just won't do it anymore um
and when you look at the the death rates
and my thing is obviously with the
hormone replacement therapy
um we're putting transsexuals into a
very shallow
early cancerous grave when you actually
know what hormones do to the body
um so none of that regardless none of
that is the healthier alternative than
let's say
mental therapy that that sciences is
undeniable it is harder on the body and
it will shorten lifespan
so how do you weigh that with early
science that maybe suggests the brain
development
might be more feminine or masculine
well in the first place i the john
hopkins um
hospital they banned it way back in the
70s under the authority of
a kind of a questionable doctor who was
quite biased in his research um but
that's a whole topic for another
um for another show um
other than that yes no it's not what's
not a discussion for another show though
is that these are non-functioning
sex change operations most of them don't
go through with it because it's it's
essentially mutilation and it causes a
lot of complications so
regardless of the reason why i mean
those are those are the results i'm just
using i'm just trying to be fair and if
you say that about the ageism
it can be used as a legitimate argument
and changing your your sex
i i as i said i don't really think it
can okay
um um as i said i've i've read the
research i've read the studies
um there's a really good evidence um
even trans people who haven't gone
under hormone therapy that they have
into sex conditions in their brain
um and i've done extensive research on
this
and uh that's kind of the deal breaker
for me um
is that's that's to me the fundamental
difference between someone who
claims they're tr their their trans age
when
you look at their brain and it's
obviously not uh whereas when you look
at transsexuals brands
it's there's obviously um there's some
science behind it
um i work with a lot of special needs
people and a huge measurement with that
is well they have the brain that's
developed to that of a 14 year old or a
six-year-old so there's
science behind that so yes exactly but
but that
that is the main that is a mentally
disabled person
so do you think that stephanie is
basically trans [ __ ]
no she would look at her brain and
or his brain and um i don't know what
that
like i don't even know well see how do
you not know because it's a
he claims to be a woman now that you
just disrespected the pronouns
um oh wait so sorry sorry we have to go
to the break we'll be we'll bring you
right back there admire louder with
crowder stay tuned
glad to be back glad to be here and uh
returning with our guest
theron meyer what's the youtube channel
theron
it's just there in maya it's my it's my
name okay well
h there we go and we appreciate you
coming in you came in from mexico so i'm
sure you're all screwed up on the time
zones did you enjoy your your time there
in uh
in cancun i did i had a lovely time um
on like some resort with my family
uh first time we were all together in
like two years because we're all over
the place
okay i i hate to vilify an entire nation
of people but mexico is a terrible place
when i went i could not stand mexico it
was like cancun the resort we were there
for the climate summit and then we went
to the actual
villages to see how they lived and of
course no one else did
okay i have to ask you because mexican
you know very catholic
not quite the same as the united states
how did they react to the the
transsexual deal
nobody really suspected anything i
didn't i really i didn't get any
problems i was in my bikini
well forgive me for asking okay you're
in your bikini um and you can always
feel free to say
no you don't want to answer any
questions okay you have that right but i
obviously i'm curious you're in your
bikini uh you haven't had your sexual
reassignment surgery i'm guessing
well i wear a bathing okay maybe bikini
was the wrong i wear a bathing costume
that is fitting for my body time
oh okay okay that's as much as i will
say
okay good okay so they wouldn't so they
wouldn't be able to know
well no no i i make sure that i
pass and i assimilate okay i don't want
to deal
i don't want to deal with with nonsense
do you have you done the top surgery
i haven't not yet okay okay so i'm just
making so now you were
as i said bikini a bathing costume for
my body type
okay no that's fair you know listen we
don't know these things
um and i don't know i don't find these
questions just so you know
yeah well listen if you came on the show
where we play spot the [ __ ] will you
will you play that with us that would be
awesome if you came on and played spot
the [ __ ] with
with not gay jared sure i'll play spot
the trony as long as they don't get
called men
what if they are men some of them that's
the thing some of them are and some of
them aren't that's the key to the game
well that's the key well unless well
well some of them are cisgender woman
and some of them are transgender women
but you don't know that's why you have
to guess
so the whole point is that in guessing
you might be guilty of hate speech there
and
that's the key to the game okay um
so you said during the break you don't
really
you don't believe in the assignment
surgery but you do do you do the hormone
replacement therapy
yes i'm on hormones and you know you're
right like
there are definitely health effects um
to
going on testosterone and going on to
estrogen um
everything in life is a trade-off i'm
much happier
on hormones i know there are health
risks um
if you if you live a healthy life and
and you exercise and you eat healthily
uh you should be fine that's not true i
will tell you that's not true with
estrogen
testosterone slightly elevated
testosterone but a man pumping his body
it's a it's very cancerous i'm sure you
must know that they must have warned you
about that
no no i my doctor did not tell me about
that i'll have to look into that yeah
she did not well let me ask you this
she's a very she's she's a
pretty experienced long time practice
tell me about the health risks um and
the risks of breast cancer
yeah well not only breast cancer but for
men all kinds of of cancer even just a
slight elevation
i mean that's why that's a big reason
why um you know people go to organic
food and try and avoid bpas because of
xenoestrogens which mimic estrogen in
the body
and they argue that these minuscule
amounts can cause cancer the big reason
for these
sort of the and that's not necessarily
true right pesticide minuscule
but that's the argument they make it's
largely based around the idea of excess
estrogen in the body so the proof that
we have is if you inject estrogen
you are far more increasing your chance
of getting cancer than let's say you
would have lung cancer with even tobacco
far greater yes and that's also
it also has to do with the receptiveness
to estrogen because
some genetic males aren't receptive
to estrogen very much at all so they as
you said do have to pump
a lot of estrogen into their body yes
well they're pumping estrogen like
bodybuilders are steroids in the flip
side
and uh except estrogen is even worse for
the male body okay
so with that being said so you're you're
open about these like well listen
they're health risks and you just
yeah you're willing to accept them
because you're happier yes i am happier
okay so we saw with like ben shapiro
for example with uh i'm not respecting
the pronouns here but because
he said he was going to kick ben
shapiro's ass which just in my head does
not register as feminine zoe tur
who i believe is a sociopath um ben made
the point and i've been making this
point for a while
you talk about pronouns i did the gender
pronoun video where we've been
basically instructed by the social
justice warrior left to ask for pronouns
to what point are other people who
disagree with you respectfully
i disagree with a lot of what you've
presented are they required to
participate if someone just is unable to
use those pronouns if someone just
doesn't recognize it like many doctors
where do you file that ignorance hate
speech um
um well if someone doesn't like use
my pronouns that's fine i'll just not
really communicate with them any longer
i'm not going to get offended i'll just
respectfully withdrawal um but i don't
i don't i don't see the i don't really
see the the huge
like for example this zorrito
absolutely insane absolutely
unacceptable
um you know threats of violence that's
totally unacceptable
i mean i disagree with a lot of um
what ben shapiro you know what benchmark
says but
at that moment i was totally on ben
shapiro's side
and you know he actually put forth some
rational argument of
why uh he should call
um her he you know he actually put
forward the rational argument everyone
else on the other side
they were just like uh well you
shouldn't because it's disrespectful
or you're hateful or whatever those
aren't arguments
you know at least you put forth an
argument i mean i may not disagree i may
not agree with the argument
but it's a lot more of an argument than
the other side gave
uh so yeah totally on on his side in
that moment
well i think that's reasonable i think
with your permission we should you
should be labeled
the reasonable training the reasonable
transgender um you have to admit it's
there's not a lot of reason coming out
of that community right now here's my
problem with stephanie
there are people like you who say who
are obviously well thought
uh well spoken but stephanie was
widely embraced by the enough by the
trans community that the
center for transgender the project
whatever it was and these church
yes and enough that at all the parades
they
laud him her as a hero
um so you have to you're in a minority
in the transgender community
um i don't really know if i'm a minority
because i speak to so many trans people
but it's just like
there's this really vocal uh sick
and um they're they're the one who
pushed political transgenderism you know
they pushed
they push trans politics the rest of us
are just trying to live our lives you
know
there's so many of those kinds of trans
people uh who
kind of you know connect with me and
like yeah i really agree with you
and i feel the exact same way i'm so
tired of this nonsense
from uh you know the political camp of
of the trans community you say that but
it's inherently let's say okay the
bathroom example
where do you line up on that does the
state have the right to say no if you're
if you if you still have a penis if
you're still
uh biologically a man regardless of your
hormones you use the men's room
no i don't think the state has the right
to say that i think
individual uh businesses have the right
to say that
well the state has it just it's been
brought up to the state level you know
like you see that that's where the
complaints have come so
at that point it is at a state level
yeah i don't
i don't necessarily agree with that okay
so you don't believe the state like i
think
texas was it texas it was houston and
philadelphia like a city ordinance or
like in new york now in new york now
yes okay so you know about new york if
you own a building
in your your own building you say no no
you use your gen
your birth assign sexual uh orientation
sexual gen sorry
that's all you know what i mean the
bathroom if you have a penis you use the
men's room if you don't
you believe a private business owner
should have the right to say that and
not be fine as in new york
no oh my god no that's
ridiculous that was so i mean i just
wouldn't go to that business
because i think that's silly and
honestly like i've been using the
woman's washroom for so long and
nobody really realizes and it's not it's
kind of a non-issue
for me um but i realized how it could be
an issue right so i understand
so i private businesses should be able
to do that i'm not gonna lie you're
pretty
come on not gay jared theron you
wouldn't know
no no if we played theron on spot the
[ __ ] we would both
we would both say woman yes we would not
be like stephanie
oh you guys are so sweet
well i think facebook removed that for
hate speech um
someone did remove it for hate speech
yeah okay so i can see but
you know like we had um at planet
fitness here in michigan if you saw that
that was just a guy in a dress it was
very clearly a man
and it's not unreasonable for a woman in
a changing room
at a gym to feel uncomfortable for a guy
in a dress to go in
is that fair i can understand that i i
totally can't that's why this is kind of
a tough
topic seems to be one of those one top
one of those problems that would never
really be
resolved that's how i feel like
sometimes yeah
i don't think it is going to be resolved
necessarily i mean there's also the
wrinkle in there that um
well you're not really a feminist but
you know women who think we've
experienced this whole life as a woman
and a guy changes later in life you
can't really understand the
um the plight or the well you can't
right well well i i don't i don't
experience i don't know
what is what a cisgender woman's life
experience was i wasn't raised as female
i
went to an all-boys school uh for most
of my life
i don't know i have a totally different
experience but i'm an individual this is
all collectivist crap
i don't have time for it you went to an
all-boys school i did
oh that's that was fun
i was going to say that's uh that's you
kind of went the other way
conservative south africa is there
really what's conservative south africa
what does that word mean there
does it mean well i just like the
traditional
afrikaans community very um
very religious very conservative
you know and that was a big problem for
me growing up
but as i've kind of like matured more
i kind of look back and i see all of the
value that i've gotten from conservatism
and conservatives
in my childhood so it's not all that bad
but there is some of it well okay so you
you know you go with the milo premise
which i can appreciate
is you because it has to be predicated
on the idea that there is a male and
female brain
now what you may not realize is that
inadvertently makes the argument
um against same-sex marriage
in the sense that there are inherently
different brains and roles for gender
that they can bring to rearing a child
because men and women are not
interchangeable that's i agree with you
on that
stephen and i've heard you say that and
i totally agree and
um i value having had a mother and a
father
uh i don't think that uh
while i don't i'm not against same-sex
parenting i don't think that the
ideal family structure would do you know
what i mean like
i agree with you yeah yeah i agree with
you people want to have same-sex civil
unions but as far as i'm concerned
i've talked about this with adoption
mother
father and then way down the list single
mothers
or same-sex parents just because the
ideal is a mother a father again because
there are things i believe that a mother
can bring that a father can't bring
doesn't mean ban it
talking in order of priority because you
can't even adopt a child if you have a
job that is inflexible
um i have relatives who had problems
with that all right theron we must go
one last time where can people find you
on the interwebs
do find me on um on youtube it's just a
fair and my my name
t-h-e-r-y-n-e-m-e-y-e-r and hopefully
there will be a link in the low-ball
when this becomes a video yeah
um and on twitter the same thing theron
meyer out there in miami
um yeah well thank you very much then we
don't agree on everything but reasonable
right not gay jerry that's okay yep
more agreements more reasonable than
jared all right we have to go
thank you so much louder with crowder we
will be back to wrap this up
in a neutral gender neutral i missed
i missed hey if you like this video
subscribe by clicking my face or
the button above me or one of these
videos next to me it's all free if you
don't like it
i can take off my glasses i can be
whoever you want me to be okay internet
love me i need your affection what are
the latest polls